the morning everyone welcome to this
extraordinary meeting of cabinet so
without further ado apologies for
absence Thank You Caroline
disclosures of interest any disclosures
of interest no so mutters to be referred
to council site allocations plan
proposed submission will ask mr.
Carrisford if he will introduce this
Thank You Lee that area good morning
cabinets and said the report before you
today members is the site locations plan
proposed submission version to agree
it's for statutory public consultation
in essence this is the plan the council
wishes to submit to the government for
independent examination a subject of
course change changes arising out of the
Constitution itself so although the plan
is a right and when formally adopted who
sits alongside the core strategy it is
subservient to the core strategy it's a
tier 2 plan that is important because
the site allocations plan has very
specific purposes and it's being
prepared in the context set by the core
strategy it is a stopgap measure now to
2031 so what it doesn't do is revisit
the housing requirement or the
development strategy and in these
respects we'll be moving to review of
the core strategy that from next year so
if I can just briefly outline the site
allocations plan does include
we've got reserve housing science which
is policies SAP one in SAP to myself
building custom-built home sites
policies up three to SAP five built up
here boundaries SAP six enabling science
up seven April 6 safeguarding sulphate
and then there are a range of various
specific proposals now I don't propose
to run through all the voter proposals
now but thought it might be a useful
just outline the approach to reserve
housing science if that's beneficial for
members leader and also lead happy to
answer any specific queries of members
might have about specific proposals so
in respect of reserve housing science
the core strategy commits this council
to identifying reserve equivalent to
twenty percent of the housing
requirements
that's 2020 homes and the core strategy
also establishes four reasons for
identifying those reserve science and
they are short for a five-year housing
round supply additional homes relating
to additional additional jobs from
hundred hectares employment allocation
at gate and nine or 1/8 additional
housing needs in the Coventry water
housing market area outside the district
and additional needs from elsewhere so
the identification of reserve science is
based on the technical evidence postures
have undertaken and the following
approach in essence is to deliverable
sites identified in the strategic
housing land availability assessment
their sites that are not within the
green belt and they are sites that are
not within a made neighborhood plan that
is already identified reserve housing
sites
there is one final area that has
determined our strategy leader and that
is infrastructure and we've worked
closely with our partners of the County
Council to look at infrastructure issues
and it is the major constraints out in
college that's been identified up being
our capacity and importantly unlike
other infrastructure issues
it's that capacity issue in some college
is not considered to be capable of being
addressed through this site allocations
plan itself that's because it's a
specific purpose for information annex
one on page 147 the plan itself is a
schedule of those proposed reserve sites
just to reiterate the site locations
plan is a pragmatic and proactive
response to helping ensure this council
retains control of planning across the
district the Reserve sites in particular
will help prevent suspected if
application to housing schemes on the
sites wheezed elect planning authority
don't consider suitable for development
it deals with the issues we committed to
tackling in the core strategy such as
reserve housing sites and built very
boundaries but also new legal
requirements inspector customer self
field as well as a range of new
proposals that have emerged since the
core strategy was adopted again that's a
flexible approach in accordance with the
MPP F so the statutory consultation
period provides the opportunity for
anyone to say why they consider the plan
to be unsound and then set out what
modifications would be required to make
it sound so sound this relates to the
plan being positively prepared justified
effective by capable of being delivered
and consistent national policy
so by endorsing the site and occasions
plan submitting it for examination this
council is saying this because the plan
to be sound leader if I can just draw
members attention to an addendum
you have before you relating to text
that was missed off policy SAP for doing
the editorial process which I apologize
it is identical to text but is already
within policy SAP 5 but it's it's also
needed in SAP for can also go on record
leader for may my thanks to my
colleagues and the policy team
particularly Paul Harris colleagues for
their hard work in preparing the plan
that gets me to this stage and finally
leader five recommendations on page one
with your report thank you thank you mr.
Carrisford I would draw people's
attention to paragraphs 1 2 3 and 1 2 4
that the policy was stipulated by the
inspector when the core strategy was
approved reinforcing what mr. Kerr had
said the provision is to deal with the
period of time before the core strategy
is reviewed and we have to be very
careful as outlined in 1 to 4 that we do
not get into a position where there
could be accusations that the core
strategies is out-of-date and no longer
valid what that would mean is also spelt
out pretty clearly in 1 to 4 that that
means in reality we would lose control
of development and that in reality the
planning appeal system would determine
planning decisions in the district I'm
sure people realize that that is not a
position we would actually like to be in
and that is also picked up by the risk
assessment at the end of the paper so
members of cabinets any questions
any discussion just one final thing this
now goes out to consultation doesn't it
mr. carefully so that if there really
are questions of detail on particular
sites I think those should actually be
told in the consultation Thank You
leader John just one here on South build
and custom build housing sighs I take it
this is just an enhancement to what was
originally put forward is that correct
the wording so yes the addendum you
referred to and it's yes it was included
in SAP five but we it should have been
included in SAP for but we it wasn't
some error so we're just ensuring that
it's it's included as it should be thank
you clarification approximately how many
South build sites are we looking at a
new quantity because obviously we're as
I'm sure we're trying to courage
yourself build one thing we don't get is
sill from those as well so I'm just
interested to know what the percentage
would be well we have a legal duty to
meet now several needs we have a
register with hundred forty four
individuals on it you write about me
still but our obligation is to bring
forward or facilitate service ports so
we're proposing a list of things knowing
sites to self build to to address that
Thank You leader in good morning I just
wondered whether we've got an update on
the five-year housing land supply which
is that has impacts perhaps mr. careful
you could bring is completely up to date
yes we are still checking because it's
the spreadsheet this is behind it is
very comprehensive that I have sites
healthy six
but I need to confirm maths as we
finalize it the healthy six good
counselor Harvey 23.9 in the paper and
the question of Southam it's a general
question this is a constraint on our
ability to designate reserved areas in
that particular location I it provokes
the questioning in me of the degree to
which we are vulnerable in other parts
of the district to a similar sort of
constraint and I'd like to know if
there's any information on how close we
might be in other parts of the district
to that particular constraint and the
second prong of the question is that's
an education constraint are there any
other infrastructure type constraints
which are going to are likely to be
important in considering decisions can't
be made in this context specific
recently there is no doubt about it that
infrastructure constraints are quite
substantial and they cover a whole range
of things from Road capacity through to
wastewater treatment plants so certainly
when we review the strategy the
infrastructure constraints will I think
proved to be a much bigger factor in
putting the strategy together
I think it's a good question there are a
whole raft of infrastructure issues
across the district I think the the key
distinction is that whether it's health
care facilities highways wastewater the
advice we're getting is they are capable
of being mitigated and addressed
so within the crimes of the plan you can
throw money at them but they you can
resolve them the key distinction is
particularly this album and Secondary
Education Institute the timescales and
the cost of Secondary Schools it's not
considered that is something that can be
addressed pre twenty thirty one within
the framework of supplications plan when
we don't know how many if any of the
sites are going to come forward there's
a similar issue with Stratford school
that it's not as it's not as big an
issue but we have ha if you look in the
papers members you'll see the proposed
site South lost Road for educational
purposes that's to enable the high
school there to expand it's to do with
the nature of Secretary Education and
provisions given that I wasn't here
before I noticed there's a couple of
questions one was a lot is on the
timetabling because I noticed in the
last cabinet meeting that there was
something about the timing of adoption
this site allocation plan and originally
the adoption was meant to be June 2018
so we are two years late it would seem
and yet the five year landscape I is
undoubtedly extremely important so I
just wondered why there was that delay
because if it is that important then it
should have perhaps been moved on
earlier second look one is on the
consultation period it's several people
are raised to me that the consultation
period taking place on August 8th to
September the 20th covers the main
school holiday period which could limit
responses a lot of people do not meet
councils parish councils do not meet
with in August early September so that's
one issue then the infrastructure
constraints is a fair point and I think
those are far more than is actually made
out you know I think there's probably
more than just saw them that it is
covered by that but the the thing that
I'm particularly perturbed about is some
of the comments that were made in the
Stratford Observer saying that the new
core strategy will be entirely different
fight fair enough the sites are not a
starting point for the next core
strategy etc if this is the case can we
actually have some definite to legal
commitment that this will be the
actuality that that this will you know
that we can have some reassurance that
these sites are in reserve only for a
particular purpose which is to preserve
the five-year land supply and not as a
step towards making sure having these in
the next core strategy or that they will
be appropriately taken over by
developers and the reason I say that
probably is because in the corporate
strategy the action plan that was at the
last council the last cabinet meeting it
did put the site allocation plan into
cs2 a which is actually the target and
the objective is to facilitate the
delivery of housing targets so you can
see that there is there undoubtedly will
be a lot of suspicion as to why it took
two years to get to this stage why this
has come out just after an election and
the kind of they also the assurance that
people need that this is is truly a
stopgap measure that is not intended to
go into the next core strategy I think
you need to pick up the point about why
it's taken so long as you probably see
from all the background there is a huge
amount of work that goes into that I
think it will be fair to say that the
amount of work needed was underestimated
we were trying to progress as rapidly as
we could
the sheer volume of work that needed to
be done was a constraint I asked mr.
careful to come in too much in a minute
I think that this indeed is a stopgap
anyway we could make a legal commitment
to say it will never happen it is our
intention to make sure it doesn't happen
but I don't think any guarantees on that
can be given in terms of the
consultation over August and September
again it's how quickly we want to move
this forward I don't know whether
there's any flexibility in terms of
transportation but although people are
on holiday in August they are usually
present in September thank you
yes sometime table yes there has been
some the original timetable was
ambitious there's also been another work
priorities bit of taking equal priority
the there was some slippage in the terms
that it was felt that it was appropriate
that the new council made the decision
regarding the summation version rather
than it being seems being imposed upon
you by the old council so that was a
conscious decision on that front so
that's where why we are where we are the
the key date really is the submission
itself which we aim for end of the year
and it's felt the delay at this stage we
could still compensate and hit map that
in target that's partly why the the
Constitution itself is
the holidays and is giving losses
sufficient time to deal with any
comments that come in and still hit the
December submission what I would say is
that I'll see the papers are public and
if if council agreed this afternoon they
will put them on the website and
parishes and start looking at them and
mulling we may have been taking them
into account so no one has to wait until
the the consultation staffs justice you
need a start date for it so that should
give everyone's an additional three
weeks on that point in respect of the
whether we can catechol a state these
are will be developed post twenty thirty
one or won't come forward as partly the
new we give the core strategy why don't
think we can tie our hands then it's for
those decisions that's part of that
process but what I can say is give you
the assurance that if you look at
policies SAP ones aptitude they set out
the very specific reasons for
identifying Reserve sites and the
mechanisms for releasing them so that is
the like the statuary position this
would be the starting point for planning
applications you've got two policies
there saying how in the Sonic Reserve
science will operate
I consider that sufficient assurance
that they are only coming forward
purposes if they are required Thank You
mr. Kerr food council Richards thank you
the majority of my questions to be
answered over there around timescales
expecting more have all been well
expensive submit by December from then
on
what sort of times go away expecting is
it a six week public examination from an
inspector and then come back to Council
for final adoption weights in the hands
the planning Inspectorate muscat in the
hands of gods if you're planning that's
true the yes so on paper yes a spring
examination and summer adoption is
entirely reasonable and feasible Thank
You counsel JUnit just one other
question be given that it is a very
heavy document and lot to look at online
I just wonder for members whether it
will be to have one hard copy that
members could never have a look out to
to browse through the maps and look at
detail copy for members I assume you
don't mean a copy for each member
thank you just before we actually make a
decision one thing I would say is right
one thing I would say then welcome to
counselors Shenton what has really
struck me in the last 15 months since
being leader is the sheer volume of work
that goes in in terms of planning policy
and I think he's a tribute to mr.
Carrisford and his team how thorough the
work is that counselors Shenton
anyone says that you know they're going
to be a pendant page three it's just
just minor but only because we're going
to distribute this in one word form or
another
it says M PFF can we change that to M
ppm did say pendant and the page on page
13 we refer to the Quinton rail
Technology Center the very first one
we've got qtr C all the way through and
there are 10 instances of that through
that the documents again if it's going
outside
and I've got nothing better to do at
night unfortunately and and the other
one I'm not sure about this one but page
23 6.1 and it reads it is critical that
there's a realistic prospect of the site
allocation plan meeting the tests of
soundness and being legal compliant
should that be legally compliant
it's a mute point that I've only cuz it
only is the only reason is it because
it's going out of canceled Shenton and
it should be accurate sorry okay another
thing that I forgot to mention really
was that I don't want to be so specific
at this stage but there will be some
counselors that are particularly
affected in a way that maybe others
aren't could we perhaps have assurance
that if those counselors want to come in
to discuss those particular areas that
we could make sure that they are you
know there are some I know they're over
at Fannie Compton area for example
Stratford area some are particularly
affected and they have particular
concerns and I'm sure some of them will
raise that in the council this afternoon
and would say if we need to agree with
the portfolio holder our strategy for
consultation and engaging with parish
councils and the public in particular
the one point I would just make is that
this has to stand as a whole at the end
of the day so if things change there's
got to be compensating changes right
with that no more comments or questions
so cabinet can we go to the
recommendations to Council on page one
recommendations one two three four and
five
subject to councillor sentence
Corrections can't can we agree and sorry
and the additional addendum to item
three can we then agree the
recommendations on page one please thank
you cabinet I have to pick up on
apologies for absence we've also
received apology from councilor kettle
so with that other business urgent
business as there is no urgent business
I then declare this meeting of cabinet
closed